[Musique]
son histoire ses mystères
c'est le berceau d'une civilisation
raffinée plusieurs fois millénaire
ses habitants la nomme zango l'empiré du
milieu le centre du monde
nous l'appelons la chine
[Musique]
c'est le pays le plus peuplé du monde un
milliard deux cents millions d'hommes et
de femmes
ils n'ont en commun que leur langue
ancienne écrite les innombrables
prononciation de leur langue parlée en
rend la compréhension très difficile
d'une région à l'autre
[Musique]
75 % de la population vit dans les
campagnes souvent selon des traditions
séculaires
les autres s'entassent littéralement
dans des métropoles dont une trentaine
de plus d'un million d'habitants
pékin et shanghai héberge del sol un
total de près de 20 millions de citadins
et elles sont menacées d'étouffement par
un exode rural de plus en plus important
[Musique]
c'est un pays qui pratiquent le culte de
son passé mais aussi l'art d'interpréter
son histoire au gré des circonstances
[Musique]
le chinois qui constituent un cinquième
de l'humanité n'ont jamais aymonier
d'allergies aux régimes forts ils n'ont
renversé leur empereur que pour leur
substituer des oligarchies à poigne
ce pays qui se proclament centre du
monde n'en absorbe pas moins avec
avidité toute technologie nouvelle qu'il
a la possibilité d'importer il a par
ailleurs fait qu en son temps plus de
bouleversements sociaux que n'importe
quelle autre nation
[Musique]
cela ne s'est pas fait sans trouble
révolution ni répression car ici les
militaires ne sont jamais loin néanmoins
aux moments les plus agités de leur
histoire ces hommes dans le nombre
impressionnant pourrait laisser croire
qu'ils ont abandonné plus de
personnalités ont toujours vu l'un ou
l'autre d'entre eux se dresser face à
l'arbitraire ou à l'injustice
[Musique]
la civilisation chinoise a commencé de
fleurir il ya plus de 4000 ans
pour mémoire il y a à peine plus de deux
cents ans que les états unis d'amérique
sont indépendants
cinq siècles seulement nous séparent de
la découverte par christophe colomb du
nouveau monde
la chute de l'empiré romain d'occident
remonte à environ quinze siècles
c'est il ya moins de 3500 ans que vivait
moïse
et il y a trois mille huit cents ans que
vania le premier pharaon d'égypte
en chine la première dynastie impériale
est antérieure au deuxième millénaire
elle domine est une société déjà
complexe et cultiver une époque des
ancêtres des peuples occidentaux
vivaient encore dans les buts ou dans
des grottes
[Musique]
oh
avec près de 10 millions de kilomètres
carrés la chine a une superficie
comparable à celle de l'europe et à
celle des états unis d'amérique
le premier peuplement de cette région
d'attrait d'un million d'années et les
populations locales semblent s'être
développée indépendamment d'autres
civilisations orientales créée en armes
et outils spécifiques
les descendants de ces tribus primitives
sont les ânes auquel vient se mêler au
fil des siècles un grand nombre
d'ethnies
[Musique]
des premiers témoignages artistique qui
remonte au deuxième millénaire jusqu'à
l'époque moderne l'esthétique de la
culture chinoise témoigne d'une
étonnante unités d'inspiration à la
différence de la plupart de celles que
l'on rencontre au moyen-orient en europe
en afrique ou en amérique
même continuité dans le mode de vie des
populations rurales comme l'a révélé
l'étude du site néolithique de bambo un
village d'agriculteurs pêcheurs situé au
bord du fleuve jaune et few de 6000 ans
on n'y a exhumé en 1952 les fondations
de 45 maisons il ne croit paul et de
nombreux objets utilitaires
[Musique]
à l'époque de la guerre de troie la
chine était dominée par les chants des
tribus du nord du pays
ces guerriers délaissé la poterie pour
un bronze d'excellente qualité
il utilisait surtout cet alliage pour la
fabrication de leurs armes
poc la maîtrise de ces techniques
assurer la richesse et la puissance
le bronze servait aussi à confectionner
des accessoires destinés au culte des
ancêtres très imprégné de magie
m
la dynastie des shang laisse sa place à
celle de leurs voisins occidentaux les
choux
la fondue faire entraînant un nouveau
raffinement dans l'art ornementale mais
surtout une amélioration de l'outillage
qui permis un développement de
l'agriculture
nietzsche ou adaptés à la religion de
leurs prédécesseurs à leur propre
culture céleste et renoncèrent ton
sacrifice d'humains
à la dynastie choo la plus longue qu'ait
connue la chine succéderont durant deux
siècles d'innombrables marronniers et
des guerres locales menées par ces
seigneurs féodaux
[Musique]
dans ce climat de violence de complot et
de trahisons vont être à cette époque
plusieurs philosophies d'équilibré et
d'harmonie dont la plus célèbre est
celle enseignée par confucius un
humaniste pragmatique qui prêchent le
juste milieu entre la nature et
l'éducation l'accomplissement du devoir
plutôt que le profit et pour les
souverains un despotisme éclairé qui
doit les faire aimer de leur peuple
un langage alors en parfaite
contradiction avec les intrigues des
petits potentats au pouvoir
confucius qu'on soit un homme idéal
parfaitement maître de lui capable de
résister sereinement aux mauvais coups
du sort là où d'autres céderait à la
précipitation
cet homme c'est agir si le moment est
venu et s'en abstenir si l'action
entraîne un risque inutile
la base de toute société harmonieuse à
la famille et la piété filiale est la
première des vertus et ses conséquences
logiques sont la continuité des
traditions et le culte des ancêtres
le confucianisme nani préoccupations
métaphysiques ni dogme absolu ni clergé
plutôt qu'une religion c'est une sagesse
un art de gouverner pour le prince une
morale pour les intellectuels et une
fidélité au passé pour le peuple
cette doctrine a avant tout le goût du
concret
justice discipline ordre social vertus
familiales éducation des masses
sous sa forme primitive plus amendé dans
un sens plus religieux le confucianisme
demeurera pendant près de deux
millénaires le culte dominant des
chinois
aujourd'hui il est radicalement condamné
par les idéologues communiste qui le
juge conservateur paralysant et
responsables de l'affaiblissement de l'
empire
[Musique]
contemporain réputé de confucius lao
tseu est en fait un personnage quasi
légendaire on lui prête un ensemble de
préceptes qui sont à l'origine du
terrorisme
cette mystique visa ni mortalité
corporelle
lesage et accède grâce à une ascèse
intellectuelle qui le délivre de toute
contingence
les chinois en appel ce concept tard il
le représente par un pied marchand et
une tête humaine symbole d'un homme
avance en toute quiétude sur un chemin
sans embûche
le taoïsme est fondée sur les forces qui
régissent la nature la terre l'air l'eau
et sur le pouvoir de contraire ondrais
lumière masculins et féminins dont est
mauvais chaud et froid
[Musique]
ces éléments opposés s'attirent et se
repoussent alternativement et chacun des
extrêmes est nécessaire à l'équilibré de
l'ensemble
toute vie et changement et alternance
rien n'est statique
les chinois ont traduit ce concept
graphiquement en trial de symbolique
composé de lignes pleines et de ligne
brisé
[Musique]
les lignes pleines représente le
principe qui angle le père le pouvoir et
sial
les lignes brisées représente le
principe in la mer la soumission la
terre
[Musique]
les 64 combinaisons possibles entre ces
lignes figurait déjà dans un traité de
divination antérieure à la hausse
les caractères chinois sont bien plus
modulable encore tracy au sommet du
cygne cette ligne signifie le ciel
surplombant les hommes et sur lequel les
dieux font tomber la pluie
la même ligne signifie ici à terre sur
laquelle soulève le soleil et sur
laquelle vit l'humanité
[Musique]
voici le signe qui signifie bombes
placées sous un toit il devient bon
ordre
[Musique]
les crues du raca it était instituée
depuis ces drames décrivant des gestes
ou des objets relativement faciles à
interpréter avec le temps elle évolua se
compliqua les symboles apparurent de
plus en plus abstrait
par exemple l'ancien signe figurant le
mot prince dessinait de bras rejoignant
le ciel et une bouche qui permet de
commander au fil des siècles l'un des
bras se transforma en une sorte de
fourche représentant à la fois le temple
le pouvoir
[Musique]
ainsi les symboles ce style isère
jusqu'à ne plus ressembler que très
vaguement aux pictogrammes originaux
aujourd'hui les chinois parlent des
centaines de dialectes qui n'ont pas
plus de rapports entre eux que le
portugais n'a avec le russe mais la
langue écrite reste compréhensible à
l'ensemble de la population instruite
[Musique]
et la calligraphie qui consiste à tracer
les signes avec un pinceau constitue non
seulement la méthode fondamental de
communication mais une véritable
discipline artistique
la tradition affirme que les huîtres et
fondamentaux de la calligraphie se
trouvent réunies dans le caractère yang
qui signifie éternité
tout comme les caractères sans lasser de
cette écriture plusieurs fois millénaire
le sol et la mentalité chinoise se
fondant détonnant monuments comme
l'escalier du mont taille sept mille
marches gravies autrefois par confucius
lui-même
200 ans avant jésus-christ la chine
retrouve à une certaine unité sous
l'autorité d'un seigneur de la guerre
cheng prince de cain un homme volontaire
si l'on en croit la légende qui raconte
comment il accéda au pouvoir
suivant ce récit l'exercice de la
royauté exiger la possession d'un vase
magique or il arrive à que ce vaste
combat par accident au fond de la
rivière
zhang ordonna qu'on leur pêche ce qui
fut fait à grand renfort de perche et de
cordes
[Musique]
mais les cordes caceres le vase disparu
à nouveau et tous les efforts pour le
récupérer échouèrent
alors chaîne décida de s'en passer il
s'empara des territoires voisins et
créer un royaume uni qu
il prit le titre d'auguste seigneur en
chinois ou en été il engage à des
réformes radicales unifiée l'écriture
les monnaies et les unités de mesure il
règlement à l'administration et
l'enseignement
il fit aussi renforcé et complété une
série d'ouvragés fortifiée qui
protégeait de longue date le nord du
pays des hordes mongoles
plus de trois cent mille hommes sur
affectés à la construction de ces civils
kilomètres de murs flanqué de tours de
guet et haut par endroits de plus de 15
mètres
cette grande muraille qui constitue la
plus immense construction de l'antiquité
à ce point solide qu'elle nous est
parvenue presque intacte
oui
les cavaliers pouvait la parcourir à 5,2
feront elles n'étaient pas conçues
seulement comme une barrière mais comme
une ligne de positions avancées
elles étaient pipés d'impressionnantes
garnison les soldats communiqué de poste
en poste par drapeau ou par signaux de
fumée leur vie était rude sous un climat
glacial au milieu de terrain puck et de
population un style
[Musique]
on a prétendu que la grande muraille
était la seule construction terrestre
qui de la lune soit visible à l'oeil nu
mais man suivant notre état moderne
c'est un ouvrage extra guînes
[Musique]
grands bâtisseurs est donc grand
mobilisateur de main d'oeuvre l'empereur
n'était guère populaire mais son peuple
déjà était passif et philosophe
aux pêcheurs du fleuve jaune et du
fleuve bleu la rivière fournit
l'essentiel l'eau l'eau des poissons
l'eau pour les champs pour laver pour
cuisiner
au delà de l'eau les montagnes qui
arrête les ennemis reviennent les nuages
qui protège du soleil
il y a bien sûr les inondations et les
tremblements de terre mais c'est la loi
des contraires qui s'impose à tous y
compris à l'empereur twenty bientôt
renversé par une nouvelle dynastique
celle des ânes
[Musique]
ce fut une époque d'importants progrès
technique qui vit l'invention de
l'énergie hydraulique de la brouette du
coulage de l'acier et aussi du papier
utilisé en chine milan avant son
apparition en europe
[Musique]
les ânes favoriser l'essor culturel et
littéraire leur influence est en et en
asie centrale et méridionale
l'influencent de ram était alors
grandissante et pour les romains la soie
était le luxe suprême pour s'en procurer
ils étaient prêts à affronter les pires
tempêtes et les pierres les plus
sanguinaires tout au long des huit mille
kilomètres qui les séparaient le coeur
de la chine
partant de l'actuelle chelsea
principales régions de production les
caravanes franchissait tout le pays
d'est en ouest traversant ce qui est
aujourd'hui l'iran l'irak et la syrie
pour arriver à la méditerranée
rien d'étonnant à ce que la chine était
et baptisé à l'époque par les
occidentaux le pays de la soie qui
enfilera son saut
[Musique]
pendant plus de mille ans que la route
de la soie sur la principale voie de
communication entre l'orient et
l'occident
un millénaire durant lequel la
fabrication de cette soir n'a d'ailleurs
guère varié
dans des élevages spécialisé d'énormes
quantités de verre produit par un
papillon appelé bombyx sont nourris de
feuilles de mûrier
les verts et clos sont installés dans
des casiers spéciaux où ils filent en
trois ou quatre jours un cocon dans
lequel il s'enferme pour devenir
chrysalide
afin de conserver intactes les cocons
pour le guidage en filature on étouffe
les chrysalides qu'ils en robe
choc cocon est constituée d'un fil de
700 à 1000 mètres de long pesant au
total moins d'un gramme
une fois traité six kilos de coke onfray
donne un kilo de soie grège après des
opérations complexes d'assemblage la
soie et hissé le finissage étant
réalisée à la machine ou plus
généralement à la main si on souhaite
donner l ouvrage une qualité artistique
enfin la scénographie qui consistera pas
un remplaçant un écran de soi entre
l'anc et son support et de toute
éternité une technique qui touche ici à
sa perfection
[Musique]
ces oeuvres réalisées en sérigraphie
illustre la très ancienne théorie du
mandat céleste inventé au xiiie siècle
par la dynastie des jo reste soucieux de
justifier leur prise du pouvoir au
détriment des deux chambres
[Musique]
ont toujours un fils du ciel régnerait
en vertu d'un mandat confié par
l'habilité à son ancêtre fondateur de la
dynastie mais si ce prince ce monde
cruel orgueilleux quitté travers le ciel
peut lui retirer son mandat pour le
confier à un homme vertueux digne de
fonder une nouvelle dynastie
un jour
décider et mer des célèbes
tous et l'est
[Musique]
oh
deux sculptures de jade en statues de
pierre et le temple en palais des
milliers d'artistes ont patiemment
réalisés au fil des siècles des oeuvres
incomparable pour la plus grande gloire
de l'empereur
[Musique]
en 1974 des paysans qui creusé un puits
ont découvert fortuitement un
inestimable témoignages du passé de leur
pays
[Musique]
situés à proximité de l'ancienne
capitale impériale qian ce mausolée est
celui du premier empereur tier one
outils
sont un beau était peu plus de sept
mille statues de terre cuite 7000
soldats et chevaux reproduit en taille
réelle et formés en ordre de bataille
[Musique]
à l'origine les soldats portaient des
armes réelles mais elles ont été pillées
par des paysans révoltés quelques années
seulement après lens au classement de
cette étrange armés
[Musique]
les torts des statuts furent semble
coulé en syrie ou dans des ateliers
spécialisés mais ensuite chaque puce
culte et individuellement pour
reproduire la physionomie de chacun des
militaires représentés
dans cette époque le palais impérial
accueil musiciens chanteurs et danseurs
rejoint plus tard à l'époque de la
dynastie cannes par des acrobates des
pitres des jongleurs
au 6ème siècle après j -luc les sous la
dynastie d'assumer tous ces arts se
conjuguant en un seul le théâtre
classique que nous appelons opéras
chinois
[Musique]
les souris régnèrent peu de temps de 80
à 618 de notre ère une période qui en
europe est celle du moyen-âge et des
premiers mérovingiens
[Musique]
à hong kong la reconstitution d'un
village de l'époque donne une idée assez
exacte de ce qu'était la vie quotidienne
en chine il ya 1300 ans
[Musique]
les épreuves suis n'ont pas laissé une
trace impérissable dans l'histoire les
ont certes entamé la restauration
oise
mais si on évoque l'origine c'est
surtout pour y situer la poche du
bouddhisme donc cette région d'asie
[Musique]
c'est par la route qu'utilisaient les
caravanes pour transporter leur soit que
les chinois importés au début de notre
ère cette religion venus de l'inde
n'est 600 ans plus tôt bouda lesage
suprême mena une existence dermit qui
lui permet une illumination
il comprit et enseigne à un concept de
réincarnation en série qui forgent
chaque être aux leçons de la vie jusqu'à
atteindre la sagesse pur le nirvana un
état de béatitude qui met enfin l'âme au
diapason de l'univers
[Musique]
les moines bouddhistes s'installèrent en
chine par milliers grave en
d'innombrables effigie du grand sage
dont les traits s'inspirer de ceux des
populations locales
le bouddha historique est en nirvana
c'est à dire et un son culte prévoit
d'ailleurs l'existence d'un certain
nombre de bus la future en attente
d'incarnation
par tolérance impériale les bouddhistes
étaient exempts d'impôts ils furent donc
jalouse et au 9ème siècle quelques
quarante mille de leurs temples et
monastères furent fermées pourtant de
grande secte bouddhique spécifiquement
chinoise que nuire à la même époque leur
âge d'or comme en témoigne ce monumental
bouddha ainsi qui trône au confluent de
trois rivières près de leshan dans la
province de sechuan
[Musique]
sa construction débuta en 713 elle
durera 90 ans 100 personnes peuvent se
tenir sur chacun de ses pieds de 9
mètres de long
[Musique]
les moines d'ailleurs ce colosse de 71
mètres de haut à flanc de falaise face
au confluent pour préserver dit on les
mariniers de la noyade est la ville des
crues
les deux tiers de la surface de la chine
sont montagneux et c'est l'une des
raisons de l'entassement des populations
dans une portion réduite de terres
cultivables
la plus illustre de ses chaînes de
montagnes est évidemment l'himalaya
située au sud ouest du pays et qui
culmine à près de huit mille huit cent
cinquante mètres
ce gigantesque obstacles naturels a
toujours entravé la circulation des
hommes et des idées
le bouddhisme c'est pourtant implantés
dans cette région le tibet avec plus de
succès que partout ailleurs en extrême
orient
c'est une religion qui s'accommode mal
de régime autoritaire les tibétains
n'ont jamais fait bon ménage avec leur
puissant voisin du nord et de l'est
il est vrai que ces derniers ont crû
régulièrement la tentation de faire main
basse sur le pays
soumis aux mongols du 12e au xviie
siècle le tibet a ensuite été occupées
quasiment en permanence par les chinois
salut ma mini sera facile et religieuse
va se confier à la hiérarchie déguster
la pauvreté de cette population de 2
millions et demi d'habitants et la
réalité du pays n'en vient le très
attirant pour posséder le tibet c'est
contrôler cet himalaya qui décourage
toute velléité d'invasion venant du sud
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi la situation s'est
envenimée lorsqu en 1959 les tibétains
qui réclamait en vain une réelle
autonomie se sont révoltés contre la
tutelle de pékin la répression fit en
quelques jours dit militer
depuis leur invasion du pays en 1951 les
communistes s'étaient efforcés de battre
en brèche leur ferveur religieuse de la
population dans ce domaine aussi il est
appliqué à la même heure forte en
quelques années 2000 monastère furent
démantelées
il n'en reste que quelques dizaines le
nombre de moines à sa volonté de servir
à un millier
[Applaudissements]
il en fallait plus pour soumettre ce
peuple au caractère bien trempé par des
conditions extrêmes un peuple qui
persiste à considérer que rien ne
justifie sa soumission aux chinois ni sa
langue n'est son espoir n'est surtout sa
religion
les drapeaux de prière continue de
flotter sur le village le peuple réclame
le retour du dalaï lama chef suprême du
bouddhisme tibétain
menacé d'arrestation en 1959 et qui vit
depuis en exil
ces sujets ont payé cher leur volonté de
défendre leurs différences et leur
autonomie depuis la rébellion de 1959
une série de révoltes armées a coûté la
vie à près de 150000 des bêtas tués au
combat exécutés ou disparus
[Musique]
les chinois qui utilisaient l'imprimerie
à caractères bien avant gutenberg passe
à juste titre pour un peuple créatif au
xième siècle ils découvrirent l'aiguillé
monte et la boussole compléter leurs
connaissances en astronomie et donner un
essor considérable à la navigation
[Musique]
on assimile à ce point les mots chine et
porcelaine qu en angleterre ils sont
synonymes dans ce domaine aussi les
chinois avaient des siècles d'avant sur
les européens les plus belles oeuvres de
leurs manufactures date des époques tang
et sangles du 7e au 13ème siècle
faut-il rappeler enfin la plus célèbre
de ses inventions la poudre mélange de
salpêtre et de souffle à ces biens à
vendre 1000 dans son application la plus
pacifique la fabrication de feux
d'artifice
du 7e au 10ème siècle la chine ne cessa
de prospérer sous la dynastie tang la
capitale zhong man était alors avec un
million d'habitants la ville la plus
peuplée du monde
suivant le principe fondamental de
l'urbanisme chinois elle était bâtie en
damier chaque élément étant fortifiée et
hiérarchisées selon son éloignement du
centre
[Musique]
cette ville a pratiquement disparu mais
son plan urbain fut utilisé bien des
siècles plus tard pour la construction
de la cité interdite à pékin
[Musique]
l'enceinte extérieure abritait la ville
proprement dite les bâtiments
administratifs les boutiques et les
marchés quant aux maisons blues elle
était proche du palais plus leurs
habitants étaient du statut élevé
tous les portails ouvrait au nord car
l'empereur devait toujours être approché
par le sud d'où souffle les vents
favorables
alors que le nord n'amène de tempête et
invasion
quant au coeur de la cité le palais seul
le souverain avait le droit d'en
concéder l'accès à quelques 10000
serviteur est privilégiée
le contraste était d'autant plus
frappant entre ses 62 hectares de
splendeurs et les conditions de vie du
commun des chinois
oh
[Musique]
derrière ces murs pour trait au 2 10 m
la vie était régi par une étiquette très
strictes sous l'oeil sans pardon du fils
du ciel six agents sur le trône du
dragon l'empereur omnipotent au point
qu'il avait seul le droit de porter du
jaune et du vert millions ces couleurs
personnel
[Musique]
entre ouverte au public peu après la
proclamation de la république en 1911 la
cité interdite accueille aujourd'hui des
flots de visiteurs chinois et étrangers
[Musique]
quelques-unes des 9000 pièces du palais
impérial ont été transformés en musée on
peut y admirer les trésors impériaux
parmi lesquels des collections
inestimables de gravure de calligraphie
et surtout de ses aquarelles qui
replonge inlassablement dans
l'inspiration typique des artistes
chinois puisé dans la nature sa flore et
sa faune sauvage ou familières
[Musique]
prisé des peintres ses montagnes ses
falaises ses fleuves servait aussi de
rempart naturel aux intrusions
étrangères l'empiré du milieu entendait
bien conserver sa superbe indépendance
et ne régler qu'à sa guise ses rares
contacts avec le monde extérieur
les siècles passèrent au rythme de l'eau
qui ce des versions les rochers et les
empereurs finir par s'assoupir dans la
quiétude de leur isolement
en se consacrant entièrement
l'ébullition au spéculation
philosophique et au dilettantisme ils
perdirent toutes leurs ressources
derrières
[Musique]
les minots qui ne manquèrent pas de
mettre cette imprudence à profit ils
déferlèrent vers le sud balayèrent dans
quelques mois la dynastie des jin au
pouvoir depuis un siècle et établir un
immense empire ses talents de la russie
à la corée
kubilaï petit fils de gengis khan se
décréte a souvent de cette ville
réunifiée est au sommet de sa prospérité
la chine que découvrit marco polo en
[Musique]
lorsque les lustres marchands vénitiens
de gagner à l'occident dix sept ans plus
tard on refusait de croire ces
descriptions d'une société chinoise
élégante et raffinée la noblesse
européenne ne pouvait évidemment
accepter l'idée qu'il existe à à l'autre
bout du monde une cour infiniment plus
policé que la sienne
[Musique]
en cherchant un raccourci vers l'inde et
vers la chine et en découvrant presque
par hasard un nouveau monde au delà de
l'océan atlantique christophe colomb
allait mettre au plus encore à la mode
un certain exotisme
oh
en cela les chinois avaient
effectivement tout pour attribuer à
commencer par leur accoutrement
chapeau à plumes et longue robe de monts
dahra
pour les femmes d étoffe de soie et de
satin
les robes safran des moines
ces tenues spécifiques de chaque
catégorie de militaires
tout personnage de quelque importance
pour cadre cette société un vêtement
permettant de déterminer au premier coup
d'oeil son statut social
[Musique]
oh
au bas de l'échelle les paysans et les
pêcheurs travaillant dur pour les
propriétaires et les seigneurs locaux
on
hier comme aujourd'hui la plupart des
villages étaient bâtis le long des cours
d'eau
et qui sont en chine le sens de la vie
certaines de ces cités pouvait rivaliser
avec venise par le nombre de leurs
canaux ouverts aux transports et le
commerce
les chinois utilisaient des systèmes
d'écologistes els 3e siècle avant
jésus-christ 1400 ans avant leur
apparition en occident
des millions de gens vivaient en
permanence sur l'eau dans leur bateau
transformé en habitation
oh
peu de choses ont d'ailleurs changé dans
ce domaine sur les dizaines de fleuves
et les milliers de rivière qui offrent
40000 km de voies navigables
mais aussi une irrigation intensive des
rizières et un vivier de choix pour la
pêche
[Musique]
une ville immuable apparemment simple
mais néanmoins soumise aux éléments les
inondations
les orages la mousson
[Musique]
une existence qui confine souvent à la
pauvreté la plupart de ces familles
itinérantes transporte avec elle tout ce
qu'elle possède
oh
[Musique]
oui
en
à pékin lemmings successeur d empereur
mongol vivait dans l'opulence au xvème
siècle leur pays possédait sur l'europe
et n'avance techniques et économiques
tels qu'ils les amas sert une immense
fortune
[Musique]
la plupart de ces trésors seront
confisquées par les japonais durant la
seconde guerre mondiale ou emportés à
taïwan en 1949 par les nationalistes en
fuite
[Musique]
oh
quelques merveilles coûteux aux - gps et
pillages
ainsi le temple du ciel chef-d'oeuvre de
l'art religieux construits sous cette
même dynastie ming
deux fois par an accompagnée de milliers
de serviteurs et de notables l'empereur
qui était son palais pour s'y rendent en
grande procession
il était interdit au peuple sous peine
de mort d'assister au passage du fils du
ciel
arrivé dans l'enceinte du temple le
souverain priait pour la qualité des
récoltes de passer
pour l'abondance des récoltes à venir
[Musique]
ce temple partiellement construits en
bois peut être subir comme beaucoup
d'autres monuments de pékin plusieurs
tremblements de terre il fut donc
remanier les restaurer au cours des
régimes de l'intérieur mais ils restent
caractéristiques d'une des plus
illustres dynastie de bâtisseur
car il faut rappeler que lyon où l'eau
[Musique]
à son approche annoncé par une musique
solennelle tous se prosternaient la
dette touchant le sol il eût été
sacrilège et punis avec la dernière
sévérité d'oser affronter le regard du
fils du ciel éblouissant d'or de
pierreries mais aussi de gloire et de
sagesse
[Musique]
mon
de temps à autre pourtant le peuple
appliquer lui-même la présence yens
tradition du mandat céleste autrement
dit le renversement du s'ouvrant pouvoir
en 1640 un paysan appelé lydie qu'elle
rassemble une armée de paysans
mécontents et ni pendant trois ans de
campagne à feu et à sang
il finit en 1644 par s'emparer de pékin
le dernier empereur ming se suicida qui
fait l'aventurier pris le pouvoir
[Musique]
pas pour longtemps appelé à la rescousse
par le général en chef de l'armée
impériale les mandchous ne se fier de la
prime
du nord reconnaît le groupe ce n'était
qu'un
[Musique]
précédèrent à la répression de rigueur
ils refusèrent évidemment de céder la
place
les minutes et en discuter le cas des
rebelles ayant tous les matchs où
installer sur le toit du dragon de leur
job shenzi
après sept ans de combat celui ci
il est dur à la dernière dynastie celle
d'eads singh
[Musique]
lemmings ont laissé à la postérité leur
mausolée on y accède par une allée
flanqué de statues de pierre espère
d'animaux et 12 dénis tel qu'il veille
sur les tombes des fiduciaires
cette nécropole de badaling est située à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres de pékin
les empereurs ont été ensevelis
profondément à une trentaine de mètres
sous la surface du sol avec une
profusion d'objets et de meubles
précieux
[Musique]
jusqu'à la fin du xvième siècle quelques
concubine était emmurée vivante avec la
dépouille de leur seigneur et maître
tous les trésors des ming ne fut pas
ensevelis avec eux et notamment la
magnifique couronne bleu devenu sous
cette dynastie le symbole de la richesse
et de la puissance du souverain ce
buisson de pierre et d'incrustations
précieuse fut évidemment confisqué par
les ting
durant 300 ans et jusqu au début de ce
siècle il constitue l'un des attributs
de leur pouvoir
[Musique]
en ouvrant largement leur pays aux
influences occidentales les derniers
empereurs thing adoptèrent une politique
lourde de conséquences les anglais
importèrent d'énormes quantité d'opium
comme monnaie d'échangé contre les
marchandises locales le gouvernement
chinois tente a dit mettre le holà la
grande bretagne intervient militairement
et le bien infliger la défaite et la
honte
[Musique]
la chine fut contrainte d'accorder aux
britanniques le libre accès à plusieurs
de ses ports et la cession de hong kong
cette démonstration de faiblesse exceet
à l'appétit des autres puissances
occidentales et des japonais
[Musique]
bientôt ces pays débarquer en chine des
fonctionnaires civils et militaires qui
s'arrogent le droit de gouverner juger
et punir les chinois dans leur propre
pays terrible réveil pour un peuple
maintenu depuis des millénaires dans la
certitude de sa supériorité et dont les
occupants comment s'est ouvertement à
dépecer territoire et richesses
[Musique]
une antique prophétie affirmait qu'une
femme porterait un coup fatal à cette
dynastie le prophète avait raison sotchi
l'impératrice douairière au pouvoir
depuis 1860 étaient extravagantes et
xénophobes et autoritaire
protégés par des prétoriens à sa
dévotion l'impératrice se flattait de
perpétuer 600 ans de gloire accumulée
par ses 26 prédécesseur ming et singh
l'ex-petite campagnarde devenu concubine
non de vanité ni d'ambition
[Musique]
son seul point commun avec la quasi
totalité du peuple chinois était son
mépris et sa haine des étrangers les
diables blancs
elle encourageait donc plus ou moins
ouvertement les organisations secrètes
qui méditaient une insurrection contre
les occupants et notamment celle des
boxers de redoutable fanatiques
nationaliste
né en 1896 dans les provinces côtières
de l'est l'insurrection fait tache
d'huile en gym à 1901 2 millions de
boxer envahissent pékin menace de
massacrer les européens a retranché dans
leur concession
uci prend peur elle fuit avec sa famille
axial dans le centre du pays
un corps expéditionnaire internationale
a en effet débarqué pour porter secours
aux légations occidentale assiégée
depuis près de deux mois en plein coeur
de la capitale
[Musique]
dans la foulée la russie en profite pour
envahir la mandchourie
la répression est impitoyable pékin a
mis à sac les chinois condamné à payer
une énorme amende
lorsque succi meurt en 1908 elle laisse
un pays à genoux et pour le diriger son
petit neveu pouilly un enfant en bas âge
trois ans plus tard dans le tournoi mans
des rivalités entre les puissances
occidentales l'agitation d'un fort
courant nationaliste et l'anarchie
ambiante l'application à la sauvette du
petit empereur de pacotille mais tf1
passé plusieurs fois millénaire
les chinois en plein désarroi à vide
d'un peu de liberté le bien-être hérité
d'une république
[Musique]
et elle s'annonçait plutôt mal
pour la présider on choisit le maréchal
lannes jay kai un seigneur de la guerre
sans scrupules qui s'empressa de
dissoudre le parlement s'il n'était pas
mort quelques mois plus tard la
république n'aurait pas mis longtemps à
se transformer en dictature
[Musique]
la démocrate place est à cette époque
tous leurs espoirs en sun yat sen le
fondateur du grand parti nationaliste le
clos minh tang un visionnaire qu'il
avait le sourire son pays à toute
emprise autocratique et à toute
influence étrangère
très jeune il avait été amené à faire
connaissance avec les prisons impérial
ses discours et ses écrits l'ayant fait
étiquetés comme dangereux
révolutionnaire comme preuve l'emblème
de son parti soleil rayonnant
[Musique]
rapidement écarté de la scène politique
par l'apprenti dictateur yuan shikai sun
yat sen assiste impuissant à la guerre
de succession qui suivit la mort du
redoutable maréchal
[Musique]
les manifestations d' appel à l'unité ne
pouvait rien contre la mise en coupe
réglée de millions d'individus par tels
que généraux de fortune
le conseiller militaire de sony en scène
un certain temps kai shek ses forces à
le créer une nouvelle force militaire au
sein d'une commune tangue
mais cette armée semblait peser bien peu
à côté de celle des potentats locaux
assez riche pour s'offrir une débauche
de mitrailleuses et de canons cette
démonstration de force militaire venait
à l'appui d'une politique terroriste
systématique mauvais traitements
fusillade décapitation
toute assistance ou même suspicion de
sympathie à l'égard des nationalistes et
des poumons une exécution sommaire
[Musique]
tout autre était le climat dans les
métropoles les puissances occidentales
avaient substitué l'intriguent et
surtout l'affairisme à leur politique de
la canonnière néanmoins toujours
présente
au lendemain de la première guerre
mondiale à shanghai ou à canton
fleurissaient les banques et le commerce
international ariano distinguer vraiment
ces villes cosmopolites de londres et de
philadelphie
dès 1921 un parti communiste formé en
secret proche à la lutte contre toute
nouvelle forme de colonisation il rallia
très vite la majorité des mécontents
habileté suprême il réussit à faire
alliance avec sun yat sen lui même
aucune personnalité ne pouvait mieux
fédérer toutes les oppositions que ce
personnage charismatique désigné comme
fondateur d'une chaîne moderne et
indépendante
[Musique]
à l'époque ses talents politiques
étaient comparés à ceux de george
washington
[Musique]
et à la lecture de ces professions de
foi humaniste ses admirateurs voulait en
lui l'égal d'abraham lincoln un nouvel
apôtre des droits de l'homme
[Musique]
la mort prématurée de sun yat sen en
1925 ouvrez une succession et nous
répéter le pouvoir échouent à tchang
kaï-chek qui assuma après la présidente
du crio minh tang et le commandement de
l'armée nationale qui lança aussitôt à
la reconquête du pays en deux ans il
réussit effectivement à s'emparer des
provinces centrales puis orientale il
agit moitié par force entre qu'on
pourrait nommer les paysans excédés par
les pillages et les marques propres
prêtés et moitié par ruse en achetant
ses adversaires lorsque les armes la
menace ou la négociation n'avait pas
réussi à en venir à bout
[Musique]
dans les 930 le gouvernement républicain
qui avait déplacé la capitale était à
deux doigts de réaliser l'unification du
monde chinois
entre-temps en 1927 chiang kai shek
s'était retourné contre ses anciens
alliés communistes
mis hors la loi l'un de leurs principaux
chefs mao tsé toung s'était réfugié dans
le sud créant une première phalange de
partisans arrière
dans les villes bastions de l'armée
nationaliste l'épuration anti communiste
fut impitoyable
andré malraux on a décrit quelques uns
des plus gros épisode dans la condition
humaine en décembre 1927 un soulèvement
communiste à canton suscita une
répression particulièrement meurtrière
au cours d'un soulèvement dans les
campagnes du golan un meneur réussi à
fuir après avoir soudoyé ses gardiens
les républicains venaient de laisser
s'échapper mao tsé toung
mais le mouvement communiste dans les
villes fut brisée ce coup de force ne
fait que conforter chiang kai shek
désormais reconnue sur le plan
international
[Musique]
chiang kai shek affirmant sa position de
successeur de sun yat sen en épousant en
1927 la belle soeur du fondateur de
culot min ans une jeune femme célèbre
pour son charme et sa beauté mais
question où était chrétienne formés dans
les universités américaines et qui
poussait son arrière à profit la chine
développe est
très influencé par sa nouvelle épouse le
généralissime a effectivement c'est
forcé durant dix ans de moderniser une
fille qui resta confiné aux principaux
ports il ya quelques grandes villes
ces progrès vaillant limité en régie
c'est surtout une bourgeoisie d'affaires
de plus en plus occidentalisé
[Applaudissements]
cette politique sélective masque
incomplètement la vraie chine celle des
masses paysannes
[Musique]
pour les américains pour les européens
seul un exotisme de bon ton et peut-être
une touche de mystère distinguer les
rues et les night clubs de pékin ou de
shanghai de ceux de new york ou de paris
bon
[Musique]
on
la fraîch in celle surtout des masses
misérable va basculer bientôt dans une
abominable guerre en 1931 sous prétexte
de désordre locaux les japonais étaient
entrés en mandchourie
l'année suivante s'appuyant sur une
oligarchie locale ils créèrent sous le
nom de man show qu un protectorat confie
à quelques collaborateurs à leur entière
dévotion
[Musique]
c'est le triomphe de la politique du
fait accompli
[Musique]
l'as vence japonaise est irrésistible la
chine découvre la guerre éclair quelques
mois avant l'europe c'est le brouillon
de pas mal de plus les forces d'invasion
à venir
[Musique]
les japonais inaugure aussi l'avènement
des gouvernements fantoches à la tête du
monde chaud qu il place un revenant
pouilly l'ex enfant roi le dernier
rempart manchu démissionné de force 20
ans plus tôt
[Musique]
que fait tchang kaï-chek il fait la
chasse aux communistes cent mille
partisans qui ralliait à mao tsé toung
en table un repli stratégique de 12000
km cette fameuse longue marche qui verra
seulement 8000 d'entre eux trouvé en
octobre 1935 au bout d'un an des preuves
un refuge inexpugnable à iéna dans les
montagnes du chelsea
c'est tung et instaure une nouvelle
république des soviets ses effectifs
militaires sont très modestes mais il
constitue l'un défis permanents à
l'orgueil de son adversaire
en juillet 1937 les japonais envahissent
la chine sous un prétexte à noda
[Musique]
comme l'expliquent s'est attaché
militaire américain les japonais n'ont
même pas cherché de justification
plausible
une brève fusillade ayant éclaté entre
un de leurs soldats et des militaires
chinois ils ont décrété que la cinor et
de l'âme est une éclatante réparation
ce 7 juillet conclut l'officier la
machine de guerre japonaise a une
nouvelle fois frappé
[Musique]
l'avancée des armées nippone est
foudroyante trois semaines après le
début de leur offensive
elles sont maîtres de pékin et de tout
le nord du pays enfin le bol elle
s'entend de shanghai
la société des nations proteste peine
perdue
le seul résultat concret de cette
condamnation très formelle sera le
retrait du japon de l'assemblée
internationale
avançant le long du fleuve bleu
les agresseurs s'approche de normes
quine le 3 décembre
leurs avants gardes entre dans les
faubourgs de la ville madame tchang
kaï-chek lance un dernier appel angoissé
au monde
[Musique]
la mort vient du ciel les bombardements
tue des milliers d'innocents
tandis que madame chiang kai shek appel
à une problématique mobilisation
internationale mao tsé toung exploite la
seule faiblesse des japonais leur
incapacité à imposer leur loi dans les
campagnes trop vaste pour permettre une
surveillance constante
[Musique]
mao réussi par ailleurs un coup de
maître s'appuyant sur des généraux
nationaliste proche de chiang kai shek
il oblige son ennemi mortel à accepter
une union sacrée contre l'envahisseur
japonais
[Musique]
un chef communiste l'inpi a créé des
écoles de formation à la guérilla un
autre tout et organise des sabotages sur
l'arrière des lignes japonaise
suivant la célèbre expression de mao tsé
toung tous ses partisans étaient comme
autant de poissons dans la mer
1938 concrétisa valiance insolite entre
nationalistes et communistes en leur
offrant deux premières victoires sur les
troupes d'invasion
[Musique]
la rd pourtant très mal commencé en dix
jours de siège les japonais entrèrent la
norme quineleu tous décembre 1937
la prise de la ville est restée
tristement célèbre en raison des
atrocités auxquelles l'armée victorieuse
se livra sur une population désarmée
[Musique]
durant plus de deux mois les j'appelle
son
autorisation
procès d'être des massacres collectifs
sont des civils dont le seul crime
[Musique]
le bilan exact de cette chasse à l'homme
menée pendant plusieurs semaines jamais
il est cependant certain que de
démanteler supérieure à 200 milles
éliminer la plupart du temps de manière
innovante a brûlé vif
[Musique]
la sauvagerie à 20
ça se retourne et contrôle
martyrisé jeune femme
jean pierre mas qu poussette à la
concrétisation du vieux à deux scènes
fusionner tous les éléments du chanteur
dans une grande volonté d'indépendance
cette union nationale que ni les
divisions bien entraîné de chiang kai
shek ni la foi inébranlable des
communistes
réussi à réaliser les chapeaux de la
forge gère bien
inféodé pendant des siècles au pouvoir
absolu de leurs joueurs
les chinois refusent est un esclavage
imposé par un peuple étranger et qui
plus est unanimement exécré
[Musique]
souhaité par la haine de l'envahisseur
il parlait cette fois d'une même voix
même s' il dissimulé parfois des
arrière-pensées les messages adoucissait
la même conclusion
unis dans la haine du japonais la
volonté de le rejeter par tous les
moyens au delà des frontières nationales
hommes politiques ou orateurs de fortune
militaire ou civil incultes ou instruit
riche ou pauvre tous deux 20 de jour au
lendemain autant de résistant déterminé
[Musique]
la nation entière s'est levée comme un
seul homme et couvre tous ces bandits
japonais
vous soutiendrons cette guerre de toutes
nos france
[Musique]
notre guerre est celle de la survie et
d'indépendance
jamais et résisteront jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
zhang kai shek décida alors de regrouper
ses forces à chengdu dans la province du
sichuan
il applique un en somme la tactique
adoptée 80 poteau par les communistes
face à ses propres troupes
[Musique]
de leur nouvelle retraite très bien
protégé les nationalistes pourrait
orchestrer un harcèlement dans le sucre
[Musique]
les rations de guérilla
dans sa retraite l'armée de changkai
jack applique à la politique de la terre
brûlée
les routes foot éventré les voies de
chemin de fer démanteler les bâtiments
stratégiques dynamiter les récoltes
brûler
ce qui ne peut pas être emporté qui
aurait pu servir à l'ennemi fut détruit
[Musique]
on vit alors un exode tels que le monde
n'en avait jamais connu ou 30 millions
d'âmes suivant la retraite de leur armée
pour échapper aux japonais et reprendre
la lutte plus à l'ouest
trente millions d'hommes lancé dans un
exil volontaire de 3000km
emportant avec eux tout ce qui pouvait
l'être
leurs maigres bagages personnels mais
aussi 150 mille tonnes d'équipements
industriels des montées à la hâte et
transportées en camion en charrette et
parfois dos d'homme
la chine profonde sauvé ce qui pouvait
encore l'être pour préparer la revente
[Musique]
20 millions de chinois vivent hors de
leurs frontières la plus importante de
leur communauté à l'étranger et celle de
san francisco qui compte cent cinquante
mille personnes
tous les chinatown du monde témoigne de
l'attachement des chinois à leur
tradition qu'elle concerne la nourriture
la médecine la religion ou tout autre
mode de vie
[Musique]
les premières migrations massives date
du début du 19e siècle elles trouvent
leur origine dans la politique très
répressive menée par les empereurs
mandchous à l'égard d'une paysannerie
écrasée de taxes à l'époque les chinois
immigrés en amérique furent recrutés par
milliers pour la construction des
premières voies de chemin de fer
un second exil massif se produisit entre
les deux guerres mondiales provoquée par
les luttes internes entre communistes et
nationalistes et surtout par la terreur
des japonais
[Musique]
la stratégie nippone visait à écraser la
chine avant d'attaquer les états unis
tokyo était persuadé que
l'isolationnisme des américains les
dissuaderait d'intervenir de quelque
manière que ce soit en asie
[Musique]
sur place les japonais avaient tenté de
se rallier de shanghai tchèque
mais en vain le leader nationaliste se
méfiait tout autant des nippons que de
ses compatriotes communiste avec
lesquels il finit par rompre
définitivement
affolée ne sachant à quel saint se vouer
des millions d'hommes et de femmes
continuent de se lancer sur les routes
emmenant avec eux tous leurs biens
fuyant vers le centre du pays par monts
et par vaux vers les zones les plus
inaccessibles réputée par conséquent les
plus sûres
[Musique]
s'il y avait une chose à laquelle
aspiraient chiang kai shek c'était un
affrontement direct entre le japon les
états unis l'attaqué japonaise sur pearl
harbor aura effectivement entre autres
conséquences de lui valoir l'appui
militaire que depuis longtemps ils
quémandent est en vain à washington
[Musique]
selon le vieux principe les ennemis de
mes ennemis sont mes amis les américains
expédiera leurs alliés nationalistes
d'importantes quantités de matériel de
guerre ultra moderne leur acheminement
constituait le principal problème le
pacifique était infestée de sous marins
et de destroyers ennemis essentielle
n'était pas sur
l'essentiel du transport devaient
transiter par voie aérienne mais par le
sud au dessus de l'himalaya
[Musique]
de telles expéditions ne permettait de
livrer à l'armée nationaliste que
quelques milliers de tonnes d'armes et
de munitions par mois encore fallait-il
les acheminer ensuite aux deux millions
de soldats disséminés dans le centre du
pays
[Musique]
réputé pour son franc parler et son sale
caractère le général américain joseph
stillwell s'était vu confier par son
état-major la mission de superviser en
inde l'entraînement des recrues chinoise
[Musique]
style où elle appréciait ses troupes
mais il ne se faisait aucune illusion
sur les qualités de leur chef le
gouvernement du kuomintang était
corrompu les généraux auxquels il avait
confié son armée l'était plus encore
il était en outre impopulaire auprès de
leurs hommes généralement mal nourris
mal soignée traité comme quantité
négligeable
une attaque terrestre contre les
nationalistes paraissant hasardeuse les
japonais ont eu recours à leurs
puissantes aviation lancer massivement à
l'assaut de la capitale provisoire
john king
à cette armada aérienne les chinois
n'avaient à opposer que quelques escales
dry d'appareils surclassé
[Musique]
pour
faute d'une défense antiaérienne
approprié j'aime tout ce qui peut qu une
cible de choix pour les bombardiers
japonais la ville qui comptait deux cent
mille habitants 1938 s'était peu à peu
gonflé d'un flux ininterrompu de
réfugiés dès 1940 sa population avec qui
tu plais
[Musique]
oh
[Rires]
les bombardements japonais était à
l'unisson de ce que vivaient l'europe à
la même époque il visait à détruire la
capacité combative de l'armée ennemie
mais aussi à terrifier la population
[Musique]
malgré ce déluge de feu les civils
résistèrent enterré à plusieurs mètres
sous terre les usines continuer à
produire à l'abri des bombes
[Musique]
les civils résistaient à chungking mais
plus volontiers encore dans les maquis
communiste réputé efficace et surtout
intègrent eux paient ce qu'ils
achetaient et entre deux embuscades il
aidait au travaux des champs
[Musique]
dans l'autre camp chinois la force
militaire avait plus belle allure encore
mais elle était minée de l'intérieur par
la corruption de ses chefs qui
n'hésitait pas à des données la solde de
la zone par un déficit de nourriture les
parlements de soins médicaux
les nationalistes n'avez pas le moral
[Musique]
par contre celui des hommes de mode
setting était de zenit des hommes mais
aussi des femmes désormais associé
activement aux combats comme elle
l'était à la vie quotidienne
[Musique]
indifférent à ces querelles internes des
milliers de volontaires étrangers 20
renforcer les rangs agir tel ses pilotes
américains et britanniques les tigres
volants colonel chenaux qui infligèrent
à leurs adversaires des pertes 20 fois
supérieure au cola
dès 1939 la marine japonaise ayant
renforcé son blocus les côtes chinoises
deux vingtaine accessible à tous enfin
par mail
[Musique]
la seule solution de substitution
consistait à cheminer les
approvisionnements par voie terrestre
soit en remontant la péninsule
indochinoise soit par le nord ouest en
contournant le désert de gobi
mais dans l'un et l'autre cas les pistes
étaient étroites dangereuse est exposé à
des attaques japonaise
dernière possibilité d'utiliser la voie
de chemin de fer reliant le port d'oran
moon à la chaux dans le nord de la
birmanie la route entre kunming et john
ging
mais entre les deux se dressent des
montagnes culminant à 3000 mètres et
parcouru seulement de sentiers muletiers
les ingénieurs occidentaux étaient
formels construire ici une route digne
de ce nom réclame ray 6 à 7 ans et du
matériel de terrassement moderne
les chinois ne disposait ni d'un tel
délai ni d'un tel équipement
il pouvait mobiliser par contre des
centaines de milliers de bras qui
effectué le travail avec des pelles des
pioches et à mains nues
[Musique]
au mans
oui
[Musique]
moins d'un an plus tard les premiers
convois arrivée dans la capitale
nationaliste en direct de rangoon
[Musique]
cet exploit valu à chiang kai shek à un
regain de confiance des occidentaux
même si très vite les progrès
foudroyants de l'offensive japonaise
cuper cette route de birmanie
au caire en 1943 le leader nationaliste
toujours accompagné de sa femme fut
invité à siéger aux côtés de roosevelt
et de churchill en coulisses beaucoup
commençait cependant à émettre des
doutes sur ses capacités à gouverner
retranchés dans leur fief du nord les
communistes étaient déjà en situation
d'affirmer leurs exigences en 1937 il
administrait 2 millions de paysans en
1944 plus de 100 millions mao tse tôt me
voyais beaucoup plus loin à l'époque il
s'attacha à forger son image de
prophètes infaillible
il rédigea les premiers préceptes de ce
qui deviendra trente ans plus tard une
bible politique destiné à servir de
référence à un cinquième de l'humanité
en faisant associés aux populations
rurales le terme de communistes à celui
de résistants mao créer un nationalisme
de masse qui allait faire sa fortune
politique
[Musique]
l'idéalisme américain rêvait d'une
réconciliation entre mao tsé toung et
chiang kai shek l'alliance entre l'eau
et le feu
le général stillwell prêt chez lui aussi
la réunification sous un commandement
unique des deux armées chinoises celle
des communistes et celle des
nationalistes
mal lui en prit chiang kai shek oublions
tout ce qu'ils lui devaient réclame à
son limogeage
roosevelt pris la peine d'envoyer sur
place son médiateur personnel patrick
hurley rien ni fier chiang kai shek
avait la rancune tenace
stillwell déçu et désabusé repris
l'avion pour les états unis
[Musique]
les soviétiques quant à eux voler au
secours de la victoire le jour de
l'attaqué nucléaire américaine sur
nagasaki il les envahir la mandchourie
[Musique]
les communistes russes et chinois
avaient coordonner leurs actions pour
rejeter les japonais à la mer et
s'assurer la possession de la
mandchourie une région très
industrialisée et donc stratégiquement
essentiel
mètres de la place les russes refusèrent
évidemment de l'évacuer au profit de
leurs alliés chinois mao tsé toung saura
se souvenir quelques années plus tard de
ce mauvais tour joué en 1945 par ses
partenaires soviétique
les prisonniers japonais se compter par
dizaines de milliers la commanderie des
officiers de haut rang
tous furent échangées contre de fortes
rançons
mais ce qui intéressait surtout mao tsé
toung c'était la récupération d'un
énorme butin d'équipement militaire en
échange de son appui il obtint des
russes la cession de l'armement
abandonnés par les japonais un
redoutable arsenal pour sa lutte à mort
contre les nationalistes
[Musique]
le peuple avait choisi son camp il
conservait pour symbole le soleil
rayonnant du kuomintang
mais il n'inscrivait dorénavant sur fond
rouge
[Musique]
les communistes chinois étaient à la
croisée des chemins ils hésitaient
encore à jouer leur avenir sur une
réforme agraire généralisée en 1946 le
parti franchi le pas deux mille ans de
tradition était aboli les terres était
confisquée au profit du peuple l'année
suivante les expropriations touché le
bétail et l'outillage en quelques mois
100 millions d'agriculteurs accéder
ainsi à la propriété
déjà apparaît lindau un homme qui va
compter dans l'histoire de la chine
contemporaine vétéran de la longue
marche et de la guerre contre le japon à
leur conseiller privilégié du parti
communiste dans sa lutte contre les
nationalistes
[Musique]
à droite dans l'arène chiang kai shek
à gauche son challenger mao tsé toung
à l'époque les occidentaux les renvoie
encore dos à dos sur le cuirassé
missouri les japonais vaincus ils
signent leur capitulation face aux états
unis et à leurs alliés parmi lesquelles
les chinois du moins les chinois
nationaliste car ceux ci ont bien
entendu exigé de tous les sols ici à
représenter leur pays
[Musique]
autant mart s'est tous fait un geste à
51 ans il prend l'avion pour la première
fois afin de rencontrer chiang kai shek
[Musique]
en fait les deux vieux renard n'ont
aucunement l'intention de faire alliance
[Musique]
pour l'heure chacun de s'approprier la
mandchourie d'où le japon vaincu a bien
entendu été éjecté
[Musique]
les deux armées chinoises font de la
récupération de cette région vitale une
question de principe
pressé par les américains de constituer
un gouvernement de coalition communistes
et nationalistes se livre à un simulacre
de négociation
[Musique]
cette poignée de main de complaisance ne
peuvent empêcher que deux mois plus tard
la guerre civile n'éclate
là où franchi le pas car il sait que la
nouvelle armée rouge sur classe
désormais ses adversaires dans tous les
domaines qualités de commandement
mobilité et surtout un moral à toute
épreuve
quant aux populations elles n'ont
littéralement plus rien à perdre près de
dix années de guerre les ont mises à
genoux ceux qui ont échappé aux
épidémies sont décimés par des famines
comme celle qui dans le yunnan fait à
l'époque plus de 4 millions de victimes
[Musique]
dès 1948 les communistes démontrent
qu'ils sont désormais capables de
s'imposer dans le véritable batterie à
manger les grandes villes du pays
tombent les unes après les autres entre
leurs mains et en janvier 1949 les
nationalistes subissent tu as sochaux à
500 km au sud de pékin une défaite
décisive qui leur coûte plus d'un demi
million d'hommes et une bonne partie de
leurs armes lourdes
madame tchang kaï-chek ne suffisait plus
à subjuguer le président truman
les américains étaient excédés par
l'obstination du chef nationaliste qui
rejetait toutes demandes de réformes et
s'obstine à l'envisager de solutions que
militaire tout en multipliant les
erreurs stratégiques
car plus rien désormais ne pouvait
empêcher les communistes de s'emparer de
la totalité de la chine continentale
ce fut chose faite à la fin de l'année
tandis que mao proclamer avec un
l'avènement de la république populaire
chiang kai shek les débris de son armée
et deux millions de civils se réfugier
sur l'île de taïwan
à
[Musique]
[Rires]
les hommes d'affaires étrangers eux
aussi fuir précipitamment leurs valises
à nong in à shanghai les dernières
officines occidentales plier bagage
les premiers bilans économiques du
nouveau pouvoir furent impressionnants
en trois ans les communistes jugulaire
l'inflation rétablir la production à son
niveau d'avant guerre et réaliser la
réforme agraire prélude à la mise en
place de coopératives étatique
la situation aux frontières étaient
pourtant explosive en juin 1950 le
gouvernement communiste nord-coréen
avait envahi la corée du sud dont les
dirigeants de droite était soutenu par
washington
on ne sait toujours pas aujourd'hui si
mao tsé toung fut averti de cette
invasion qui dans le contexte de
l'époque servait plus les intérêts de
l'urss que ceux de la chine occupé à
liquider les derniers îlots de
résistance nationaliste
à washington les faucons réclamait une
intervention armée le président truman
ne pouvait négliger les réticences qui
se manifestaient dans son opinion
publique
finalement c'est une force
internationale qui fut chargé par l'onu
de juguler l'invasion nord-coréenne mais
en fait il s'agissait essentiellement
d'unités américaine
mao tsé toung vit donc dans cette
opération une ingérence directe des
états unis d'autant plus inquiétante
pour lui tout quelques semaines le corps
expéditionnaire commandé par macarthur
meuh non une autorité l'hiver avait
repoussé les agresseurs très au delà de
la base de départ et même jusqu'aux
frontières de la mandchourie c'est à
dire de la chine
non
pékin intervint alors militairement
envoyés en renfort à ses alliés coréen
500000 soi disant volontaires en fait
des soldats de l'armée régulière parmi
eux le fils de mao tsé toung qui fut tué
au combat en mai 1951
[Musique]
après six mois d'offensive et de contre
offensive les deux armées furent bloqués
face à face sur le 38e parallèle
elle s'impose air durant deux ans une
inutile guerre d'usure
[Musique]
le sort des réfugiés et des populations
civiles en général n'était pas plus
enviable
encore ces dernières échappe airtel au
pire
désespérant de voir se débloquer la
situation militaire mac arthur suggéra
de lâcher quelques bombes atomiques sur
la chine
truman le releva aussitôt de son
commandement
[Musique]
pressentant une issue diplomatique qui
les amènerait à se retirer de corée les
américains détruisirent systématiquement
dans la zone encore placées sous leur
contrôle
tout ce qui pourrait servir à l'ennemi
les usines les constructions militaires
les installations portuaires
[Musique]
l'armistice signé en 1953 à panmunjom
est toujours en vigueur
en 1959 l'armée de mao s'était déjà
trouvé engagé au tibet dont les
habitants n'avaient pas eu grand chose à
opposer aux quatre cent mille soldats
chinois qui débarquait chez eux d'abord
sous le prétexte de gérer leur défense
et leur affaires étrangères puis très
vite pour les annexer purement et
simplement
[Musique]
autre région réputée autonome la
mongolie en fait elle aussi totalement
sous tutelle
[Musique]
dans les deux cas il s'agit de
territoire désertique et montagneux
considéré par les chinois comme beaucoup
plus simple à défendre qu'autrefois la
grande muraille pas plus que les
tibétains les mongols ne furent facile à
convaincre
[Musique]
ce sont des nomades pour qui la réforme
agraire n'a évidemment aucun sens il
fallut donc ici aussi de temps à autres
substituts et la force à la persuasion
et là plus qu'ailleurs le totalitarisme
chinois multiplia les campagnes
publiques qui visait à la fois à
inspirer la crainte mais aussi à
convaincre et à rallier car si les
procédures étaient expéditive les buts
ne pouvait que séduire les masses
populaires lutte contre la fraude le
gaspillage la corruption et le trafic
d'influencé
pendant 2000 ans pratiquement chaque
année des centaines de milliers parfois
des millions de chinois étaient morts de
faim le nouveau régime réussi à
démontrer que ce fléau ne constituait
pas une fatalité
[Musique]
la collectivisation des terres les
cultures en terrasse dans les zones
montagneuses
l'amélioration de l'irrigation en pleine
devait permettre à 80% de la population
active de nourrir la totalité de la
nation
cela ne se fit pas sans drame
les anciens propriétaires fonciers
d'abord dépouillé furent ensuite désigné
à l'exécration du peuple
le nombre d'exécution lié à cette
réforme économique à laquelle l'état
communiste voulait donner un caractère
exemplaire n'a bien entendu jamais été
révélée mais les chiffres avancés aussi
entre 1 et 5 millions de morts
souvent les autorités étaient dépassés
par le climat de suspicion qu'elle avait
elle même créé
dans beaucoup de communautés
villageoises les cadres du parti mise en
place profiter de leur parcelle de
pouvoir pour régler des comptes peu à
peu les théoriciens de la révolution
découvrir qu'il y à loin d'une justice
abstraite à son application sur le
terrain
le gouvernement réussit néanmoins au
début des années cinquante à mobiliser
les masses paysannes et à transformer
profondément des rapports sociaux et
politiques souvent été stables en racine
depuis des temps immémoriaux
rien ne fut épargné pour augmenter les
rendements dans ce secteur
[Musique]
les nouveaux dirigeants de la chine
était conscient que dans leur pays toute
croissance économique est tributaire du
niveau de la production agricole les
efforts considérables qui ont été faits
hier comme aujourd'hui pour limiter le
taux de croissance démographique ne
peuvent empêcher que chaque année 12 à
15 millions de bouches supplémentaires
viennent réclamer leur lot de nourriture
quotidienne
[Musique]
pressé par les nécessités alimentaires
le parti décréta en 1958 un grand bond
en avant censé faire rattraper à
l'agriculture le retard pris au fil des
années sur la production industrielle
très mal évalué cette opération
conduisit le pays au bord d'une
véritable catastrophe
elle coûte à la chine 5 ou 6 ans de
retard dans sa course au développement
dès 1949 les efforts déployés en matière
d'enseignement furent considérables afin
de réduire la complexité de la langue
écrite les signes de bain furent réduits
et simplifiée aujourd'hui le taux
d'alphabétisation varient de 30 % au
tibet à 90% dans le nord-est du pays
et il n'est plus de mise de montrer dans
les écoles des films incitant la
jeunesse à lutter jusqu'à la mort contre
les impérialistes américains et les
nationalistes terrer à taïwan
[Musique]
l'industrie subit elle aussi le marasme
cosy au début des années 60 par le grand
bond en avant à force de vouloir
produire trop et trop vite les usines
fournir des produits médiocres et le
départ des ingénieurs soviétiques qui
suivit la détérioration des relations
avec l'urss privat les chinois d'une
bonne part de leurs acquis
technologiques
ce n'est qu'au début des années 80 que
le parti ayant cesser d'interférer
systématiquement sur la planification un
nouveau courant d'émulation et de
concurrence permis de restaurer la
qualité de la production et de faire
accéder le pays au sixième rang mondial
des nations industrialisées
[Musique]
le développement économique était aussi
handicapé par la hantise d'une invasion
armée la pression maintenue par les
soviétiques le long de leur frontière
commune avec la chine justifiaient le
maintien sur pied de guerre d'une armée
de 4 millions d'hommes mais aussi la
formation permanente d'une milice
supplétive dont les heures
d'entraînement était évidemment à
prélever sur celle consacrée au travail
[Musique]
une tension renforcée par les
interventions américaines en asie est
illustrée par ce jouet qui montre un
jihai pendu par des guérilleros ce
l'échec du grand bond en avant avec un
art ce tome sur la touche
ce n'est pas pour autant que le pays
renonce à son image de gigantisme d'une
multitude voué toute entière à
concrétiser les slogans martelés par ses
chefs c'est de cette époque que date ces
images impressionnantes montrant des
centaines de milliers de jeunes chinois
officiant dans les grandes messes
organisées par le régime
[Musique]
reprenant les rênes du pouvoir quelques
années plus tard mao encouragera cette
ferveur jusqu'à la transformer en
hystérie en un culte aveugle tel
qu'aucun dictateur avant lui n'avait osé
l'imaginer
ce lyrisme de masse ne survécut pas son
inspirateur avant même les soviétiques
les chinois renoncèrent à ces
démonstrations d' enthousiasme qui
n'abuse est même plus les participants
eux mêmes
autrefois adulé comme les pères de la
révolution socialiste les soviétiques
était devenu pour les chinois au début
des années 60 des partenaires aussi peu
fréquentable que les capitalistes
occidentaux se considérant dorénavant
comme le seul héritier valable de marx
et de lénine mao tsé toung sans apporter
la bonne parole auprès des pays du
tiers-monde en asie en afrique et même
en amérique latine
[Musique]
mais en fait la politique étrangère de
pékin fut complètement faussé par la
détérioration des relations sino
soviétique la diplomatie chinoise se
contentera pendant quinze ans de
soutenir tout mouvement de libération
pourvu qu'ils soient rival d'un autre
mouvement soutenu par un spi
après le putsch au chili en septembre
1973 c'est la chine qui la première
renvoyer l'ambassadeur du régime allende
coupable d'avoir intégré des ministres
communistes pour soviétique la montre
l'expérience fera apparaître en ce qui
concerne plus spécifiquement le
continent noir une adéquation totale
entre la mentalité chinoise est cerné
peuples africains auxquels elle
prétendait inculquait son idéologie
sur le plan intérieur l'effacement
provisoire de marraud entraîneur
politique plus tôt tu dois donner aux
régions j'avais
le concède à leur rétablissement de
certaines pratiques pudiquement baptisé
petite liberté tel le droit de cultiver
une parcelle privée et d'en vendre les
produits sur les marchés locaux ou
encore une certaine adaptation des
salaires à la productivité
des méthodes précédemment jugé anti
révolutionnaires
[Musique]
l'explosion de la première bombe
atomique chinoise fut présentée par
pékin comme la démonstration d'une
nouvelle croissance et d'une
indépendance accrue notamment vis-à-vis
de l'urss
dans ce film officiel d'époque le
commentaire situe la force atomique
chinoise à l'égal de celles des grandes
puissances occidentales
ingénieurs personnel technique et
scientifique officiers et autres membres
de l'armée de libération du peuple ont
levé haut le drapeau rouge de la pensée
de mao tsé toung
leurs convictions politiques leur
créativité et la pensée du président ont
coopéré avec vigueur et détermination
pour forger cette arme absolue
c'est un gigantesque succès personnel
pour mao tsé toung conclut le
commentateur est un gigantesque succès
pour sa politique
longue vie au parti communiste chinois
et longue vie au président mao
[Musique]
on fit ensuite chargé quelques unités de
malheureux cavaliers dans la zone de
l'explosion pour démontrer l'absurdité
de la propagande occidentale mettant en
garde contre les dangers de radiation
la chine procède à d'autres expériences
nucléaires suivi en 1967 de l'explosion
d'une première bombe à hydrogène
[Musique]
ces images sur largement diffusées a
sorti une nouvelle fois de louanges
dithyrambiques à l'égard des
travailleurs soldats des scientifiques
artisans du projet nucléaire
les dirigeants chinois était alors un
capable de propulser leurs bombes hors
de leurs frontières mais leur seule
entrée dans le club atomique était de
nature à mettre en garde les puissances
occidentales a impressionné de manière
spectaculaire leur propre opinion
publique et aussi à déclencher une
contre propagande débridée en urss
les fanatiques chinois révèlent leurs
visées dominatrices sur le monde accuse
ce film soviétique
ils ont présenté cet événement leur
peuple comme un triomphe
[Musique]
mais visiblement les villageois ne sont
pas convaincus on fait la fête comme au
moment des récoltes mais on n'a rien
récolté c'est une joie mal programmées
[Musique]
la contre propagande soviétique dénonce
aussi l'endoctrinement des enfants
ces images inquiétantes devrait faire
réfléchir ceux qui en europe ce qui même
à paris défendre la pensée de mao
[Musique]
nous les communistes chinois remplacent
les jouets de leurs enfants par des
armes
[Musique]
et ce film établit la comparaison
n'est ce pas ainsi que les nazis aux
corrompus leur jeunesse
[Musique]
n'est-ce pas ainsi que les japonais ont
endoctrinés leurs écoliers
et de même les fascistes italiens
le début des années 60 marqua l'apogée
de cette guerre froide pour faire
oublier l'échec du grand bond il était
très opportun de focaliser l'opinion sur
la haine des ennemis étrangers
dans les campagnes on décréta
symboliquement la mobilisation
permanente et dans les grandes villes à
pékin à shanghai on construisit
d'immensité souterraine qui en cas de
conflit était censé abriter le
gouvernement et les organes vitaux
chargé d'organiser la résistance à
l'envahisseur avec des centres de
communication des magasins et même des
milliers de bicyclettes destiné à
assurer les liaisons dans ces centaines
de kilomètres de tunnels
[Musique]
dans les campagnes les populations
étaient entraînés à la guérilla dans la
perspective d'un déferlement russes
chaque paysan était tenue d' apprendre à
placer des pièges à enterrer des mines à
manier des engins antichar plus ou moins
bricoler et bien entendu à tirer au
fusil
[Musique]
cette recette n'était pas neuve crée une
menace en grande part fictives ou
détourner l'attention du peuple de ses
problèmes de subsistance
[Musique]
la guerre du vietnam et ses conséquences
dans l'ensemble la péninsule
indochinoise aggravèrent encore la
tension entre la chine et l'urss
moscou et pékin firent d'abord de la
surenchère dans l'assistance du front de
libération et au gouvernement de hanoï
incontestablement mao se sont impliqués
dans ce combat qui ne pouvait que lui
rappeler celui qu'il avait lui-même mené
30 ans plus tôt contre le capitalisme
[Musique]
mais les vietnamiens eux mêmes sur une
extrême prudence même au pire moment d
offensive américaine écrasée sous les
bombes et soumis à un impitoyable plus
il se gardèrent d'hypothéquer leur
indépendance en échange d'une aide
extérieure des soirées
[Musique]
l'échec du grand bond en avant avait
entraîné la mise à l'écart de mao tsé
toung mais n'avait pas suffi à l'évincer
définitivement il fit un retour en force
en 1965 en lançant la révolution
culturelle essentiellement dirigées
contre les intellectuels qui l'avait
évincé cinq ans plus tôt
le pays sombre a une nouvelle fois dans
le chaos et l'anarchie
[Musique]
au delà de l'apparence de ces images
idylliques d'un paradis retrouvé le
peuple eu à subir une nouvelle fois des
centaines de milliers de persécution
d'arrestations arbitraires et
d'exécutions
sous prétexte de retour aux sources
l'instruction la culture toutes formes
de créations artistiques furent mises
hors la loi par des cohortes d'étudiants
et de lycéens fanatisés
[Musique]
devenu sénile le grand timonier faisait
l'objet d'un culte de la personnalité
délirant mais le peuple n'était pas dupe
en 1967 il fallu faire appel à l'armée
pour briser une guerre civile
le ministre de la défense lindau tenta
d'en profiter pour imposer sa loi il fut
discrètement éliminer
le premier ministre schwahn lie appliqua
alors une stratégie modéré concrétisée
par l'entrée de la chine communiste aux
nations unies et une visite à pékin du
président américain richard nixon
le déplacement du plus important porte
parole du monde occidental connu en
outre pour ses sentiments profondément
anti communiste représentait pour les
dirigeants chinois un témoignage
essentiel de leur reconnaissance sur la
scène internationale
[Musique]
les réticences des milieux immigrés
chinois aux états unis ne pouvaient plus
rien
cette manifestation d'intérêt
diplomatique gagne à l'europe les
dirigeants allemands en menant à leur
suite quelques-uns des patrons de leur
industrie furent accueillis à pékin à
bras ouverts tout souvenir des anciennes
alliances germaneau japonaise étant mis
en veilleuse
[Musique]
l'état de santé de mao s'était aggravée
au point qu'il n'identifiait plus
clairement ses interlocuteurs comme ici
le président américain ford
les perspectives de sa prochaine
disparition firent se déchaîner les
radicaux regroupés autour de la femme de
mao changqing il rêve de prendre le
contrôle du parti de relancer la
révolution et de balayer les modérés
johann hay et deng xiaoping
mais le peuple aspire à un retour au
calme les décès de tshwane l'ail et de
mao survenu en 1976 ne permirent pas aux
champions de la ligne dure du parti de
prendre le pouvoir
dès 1978 l'histoire officielle chinoise
jetant un voile sur les dernières
séquelles de la révolution culturelle
pour les européens et même pour les
américains la chine redevenait un pays
civilisé voire à la mode par certains
biais inattendu comme l'acupuncture
on vit fleurir des cabinets médicaux
spécialisés dans cette pratique
ancestrale qui consiste à l'aide
d'aiguillés superficiellement piqué dans
des points spécifiques du corps
d'équilibrer le flux d'énergie vitale
une
à pékin la femme de mao et ses
principaux complices baptisé la bande
des quatre étaient arrêtés soumis à un
procès public et condamné pour excès de
zèle révolutionnaire à de lourdes peines
d'emprisonnement
le réformisme n'étaient plus de saison
la chine aspirait à se ressourcer
et dans ce pays les traditions ne
manquent pas celle du mariage sont
particulièrement variés ici le rite est
relativement simple on organise une
ronde et les garçons s'efforce de
séduire musicalement la jeune fille de
leur rêve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici dans les montagnes du guizhou les
choses se compliquent pendant que sa
bien aimée est censé dormir son
prétendant creuse un orifice dans le mur
de sa chambre
il y fait passer une baguette dont il se
sert pour réveiller l'élue de son coeur
la jeune fille demande le nom de
l'intrusion si le garçon lui plaît il
reçoit l'organisation de passer la nuit
sur place
sinon le prié de rentrer chez lui et on
attend qu'un autre se présente
[Musique]
car oui jura
podium iomega
[Musique]
bien une toute petite route
à
et
l'union le beijing shanghai ocs
d'al-islah
[Musique]
dans certaines régions enfin on pratique
le mariage à l'essai la cérémonie
préliminaire est très complexe et
réclame toute une mise en scène
le jeune homme entame un chant d'amour
sans s'est attiré irrésistiblement celle
qu'il aime
[Musique]
la nuit suivante il est admis qu il se
faufile discrètement dans sa chambre
[Musique]
si le lendemain le fiancé ne reparaît
pas tout est rompu et le succession ne
se formalisera pas qu'un autre les
précéder
[Musique]
en
un peu
m
[Musique]
oh
pas plus
dans les villes les rapports amoureux
sont vécues de manière très peu
romantique
officiellement interdit les mariages
arrangés restent monnaie courante
par ailleurs de nombreux tabous laisse
peu de place au rendez vous galant le
poids de la morale traditionnelle une
surveillance parentale très stricte mais
surtout les simples conditions de la vie
urbaine qui crée une terrible
promiscuité nul n'est à l'abri des
regards même pour un court moment
la vie privée telle que la conçoivent
les occidentaux n'a pas de sens dans les
mégapoles chinoises
[Musique]
certains n'ont d'autre solution que de
chercher l'âme soeur dans des soirées
dansantes sponsorisé par le parti ou
d'avoir recours à l'ordinateur
l'engin magique qui est ici comme
partout engrangé redistribue les petites
annonces matrimoniales
[Musique]
qui dit couple suggère enfant à naître
et ce problème là enchaîné littéralement
vital
la population dépassant très largement
le milliard l'état mène une politique
autoritaire de limitation de la natalité
l'objectif un seul enfant par famille
jusqu'en 2060
on à hausser l'âge minimum légal pour se
marier on libéralise l'avortement on
encourage financièrement les mariages
tardifs
mais on enregistre néanmoins 25 millions
de naissances par an c'est trois fois
plus qu'il n'est raisonnable
on se bouscule en chine et on s'écrase à
hong kong depuis qu en 1841 les
britanniques obtient une concession
extrêmement profitable sur le port et
ses abords immédiats
pendant près de cent ans l'union jack
float à l'embouchure de la rivière des
perles pour le plus grand profit de la
couronne
l'occupation japonaise n'interrompez que
très brièvement cette source de
prospérité mais en 1982 le gouvernement
de pékin se sentait assez puissant pour
remettre en question le statut du
territoire
le 1er juillet 1997 hong kong devrait
redevenir chinois avec cependant et pour
un demi-siècle supplémentaires un statut
spécial dont les termes restent à
préciser
[Musique]
main
ans
[Musique]
à la fin du siècle dernier la ville
hébergés trois cent mille habitants en
1940 ils étaient un million et demi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui 6 millions dont 98%
d'origine chinoise et pour un quart de
moins de 25 ans
c'est l'une des densités de population
des plus élevés au monde
c'est d'ailleurs la ville de tous les
records une singulière enclave
capitaliste en asie où le chômage est
pratiquement inexistant où le salaire
moyen est dix fois plus élevé qu'à 100
km de là en chine populaire et dont la
balance commerciale est en parfait
équilibre
[Musique]
si pékin a décidé de faire valoir ses
revendications sur le territoire les
chinois ne sont pas prêts pour autant à
tuer la poule aux oeufs d'or
ils ont dès à présent promis une large
autonomie à cet immense bureau
commercial où se négocie la
quasi-totalité de leurs échanges
commerciaux
l'ouverture de la chine sur le monde
occidental a également permis de
redécouvrir le panda géant espèce en
voie de disparition est aujourd'hui
protégé par la loi
[Musique]
[Rires]
le sous sol de pékin est parcourue d'un
immense réseau de tunnels dans
lesquelles ont été aménagés des bureaux
et des magasins
il s'agit en fait d'une reconversion à
l'origine c'est taupinière avait été
creusé pour servir d'abris anti aériens
au même titre que les stations de métro
cela à une époque où les autorités
chinoises considéré comme hautement
probable une guerre avec l'union
soviétique ou avec les états unis
[Applaudissements]
un
[Musique]
vieux dicton affirme ici vous n'êtes
rien tant que vous n'avez pas vu la
grande muraille
c'est évidemment le monument le plus
visité de chine
particulièrement sur le tronçon qui
franchit la passe de badaling à
seulement 70 km de pékin
[Musique]
non moins fascinante et presque aussi
fréquenter la cité interdite qu'il était
effectivement autrefois en aunis hier
mais qui abrite aujourd'hui quelques-uns
des plus riche héritage artistique du
pays et le témoignage de l'opulent
souvent indécentes des empereurs qui s'y
succédèrent du début du xvème siècle
jusqu'à l'avènement de la république en
[Musique]
face au palais impérial la place
tiananmen la place de la paix céleste
dont la superficie fut quadruplé dans
les années 50 afin de pouvoir accueillir
un million de personnes et dépasser en
gigantisme la place rouge de moscou
c'est ici qu'en 1966 mao lens à la
jeunesse chinoise dans la terrible
aventure de la révolution culturelle
c'est ici aussi qu'en 1976 cent mille
citoyens lassés par dix ans d'excès
organiseront spontanément une veillée
funèbre à la mémoire du modéré chuen lie
une fureur et une animation que l'on a
peine à imaginer lorsque comme toutes
les grandes places du monde tiananmen
est rendu aux promeneurs aux virtuoses
du cerf-volant et aux lecteurs des
journaux mureaux rédigé à la main
ouias aux bangs élu président du parti
en 1981 avait été limogé cinq ans plus
tard pour excès de libéralisation à sa
mort en 1989 les étudiants les
intellectuels manifestèrent pour
réclamer un retour à sa politique
d'ouverture
7 appellent à plus de justice de liberté
lui rapidement un écho exceptionnel
[Musique]
le 27 avril 1 millions de contestataires
défilaient à pékin le 2 mai le mouvement
gagne shanghai le 4 des milliers
d'étudiants comme sur la place tiananmen
le 19 mai le premier ministre li peng
fait appel à l'armée
[Musique]
malgré l'instauration le lendemain de la
loi martiale les manifestants refusent
de se retirer
pour ne rien apaisé cette contestation
coïncide avec une visite officielle
programmée de longue date celle du grand
frère soviétique gorbatchev déjà
considéré à l'époque comme un apôtre de
la réforme
le gouvernement chinois est en train de
perdre la face
en même temps qu'ils saluent leurs hôtes
les pékinois réclament la démission de
leur propre président deng xiaoping
des centaines d'entre eux ont maintenant
entamer une grève de la faim 1 millions
de mécontents occupe en permanence la
place tiananmen
le nouveau secrétaire général du parti
zhao ziyang est envoyé dans la rue pour
tenter d'apaiser les esprits en vain
sa démarche va même se retourner contre
lui quelques semaines plus tard il sera
chassé du pouvoir au moment du retour au
premier plan du président deng xiaoping
exit le porte parole des modérés
entre temps face au portrait de mao les
étudiants ont improvisé une statue de la
liberté drapée de rouge et de bleu aux
couleurs de la république et du
kuomintang
cette fois pour le gouvernement s'en est
trop
dans la nuit du 3 au 4 juin après
plusieurs tentatives pour faire évacuer
la place tiananmen la troupe tire dans
la foule on ignore le nombre exact de
victimes mais ils se chiffrent par
milliers
des observateurs occidentaux sur place
parlent de 10000 morts et blessés
[Musique]
une image fera le tour du monde celle de
cet homme seul face à une colonne
blindée
[Musique]
l'armée avait suivi mais pas unanimement
le parti se montrera très discret sur
l'attitude de certaines unités comme
celle de la 38e armés qui avaient refusé
de fusiller le peuple
les contestataires civils furent par
contre traiter de manière impitoyable
[Musique]
cette interview réalisée par un
cameraman américain fait pirater par la
télévision chinoise qui diffusait les
images en désignant ce dissident comme
traître et menteur
après une campagne d'appel à la délation
des dizaines de milliers de suspects
furent arrêtés officiellement 40 sur
exécuter
la suite n'est plus de l'histoire
mais l'actualité
la chine dans un premier temps c'est mal
remise de ce printemps de pékin réprimé
dans le sang
mêlé mois se sont écoulés au fil du
fleuve jaune et du fleuve bleu
l'armée et rentrer très discrètement
dans ses casernes des inondations des
tremblements de terre comme il s'en
produit tous les cinq ou dix ans dans
cet immense pays ont fait des dizaines
de milliers de victimes supplémentaires
des millions d'affamés et de sans abri
l'état essaie de juguler la démographie
galopante
l'objectif officiel un milliard cinq
cent mille chinois en 2060 en fait ils
risquent d'être près de 2 milliards
on souhaitera surtout qu'ils vivent
libres et indépendants aujourd'hui 5
millions de contestataires seraient
encore sous les verrous
[Musique]
mais tout vient en son temps en 1989 le
dalaï lama a reçu le prix nobel de la
paix en 1992 le dernier maréchal héros
historiques de la longue marche est mort
à pékin
[Musique]
partout dans le monde le génie de la
démocratie s'échappe de la lampe ou
certains ont tenté de le garder enfermé
tout voyage aussi long soit il commence
toujours par un premier petit pas
affirment ici la sagesse populaire
aujourd'hui toute une génération de
chinois a déjà fait ce premier pas
bonne route au peuple chinois